the 2017 world championship playoff
stage has come to a close and it was an
absolute thrill to watch
so let's look back at some of the very
best plays from the bracket stage
starting with this one B two out play by
team w es 9 5 7 well Nancy might already
blast ya know why connect with a slow
might still be good enough
damn it is they ain't picking it take
one turn him make it - oh my god never
up there's a banging and so many fields
fill available caps fences his chances
yet clearing out the way honest I sniff
don't feel as fast available buying some
time Busey is trying to get one back
Bing survived just a few seconds long if
you'd escaped them Alex G now in a one
feet three manages to survive
still got that goggles don't plate to
tag if he needs to real hard gonna throw
that one out there comes the Unleashed
power yet another stance always continue
to run away a thousand eight feet back
to the ground for a scone up Center
makes your way so I still not down side
step scatter the weak fall short
misfits trying to get ahead and here in
the game they got to do something now
thanks
now down and maybe able to kill on the
wolf his bank barriers out to get any
protection for him mask opens up that
could become s Katie's flash it is gonna
be the grab it is gonna be the tail he
gets out just in time and faker stays
alive get back into the fight just to
hook us over a stove Johan Samba one
more shot as wolf watch the glitter
Lance
bang the chocolate
yes misfits pull the trigger which is
good for the end all the bet gonna get a
crest on not healed my studies are
aggressive and the family began to think
yeah place up we saw plenty of Chinese
teams take advantage of the cataclysmic
entrance combo this tournament but they
were few as deadly as this wombo combo
by RNG let's find out which Fiesta wins
imagine he's gonna call you
[Applause]
everybody on fnatic the rupture throws
fnatic into the air vailable pastores as
well reckless using that Buster shutters
deputies already shut down very low
supers pouring into the Baker's me
cannot give up won't those the Chinese
members are falling left and right is he
on the run he not here to follow soon
Joseph or finds the tough to flash away
but at the 3v5 can't you win this fight
and make it down to two
to kill they feeling you start with good
look at the suppression down at the
mystic he's gonna get shut down to the
line there's still money to follow up
damage stop the house W lead unable to
find anything q bank
saves the day and rule it turns it
around as it's not too much though the
officer down here comes to read again
once again for ambition wants to add the
damage
and he's gonna fight groundless still
one netsim soon as depression comes in
four kills already one man stands alive
and he is going to fall some of the
rides to be against the back fender they
have the explosive damage they from
go name surrounded Emma Baker without a
flat without a prayer
we're kicking off our list of the best
solo kills from the bracket stage with
this intense 1v1 between w YZ GA and
sang songs QB
alright now if you pays gonna be under
further pressure it [ __ ] up for Shi a
slice enough to buy some time very
defensively even when his plane is of
doing good damage BTD gets a solo kill
the third time around 6 no harm no foul
they walk right back out of this with
the platform he's gone for the big flag
one more attack
[Applause]
well set up a couple of late until CBDT
the first game as constant using his old
for the stay alive a little longer if I
have to damage the atmosphere if you can
buy some time killer comes in for a bit
that could be exactly what long as you
need it cause with the solo kill SKT
have always had the ability to turn
around a fight but this reversal by
Union faker was absolutely nuts go to
the bot lane and here comes that slinky
does have the old fitting rod here it
comes and of course the - would have
been used flat stock of the attack he's
flaming here comes the chase down and
there's not a lot of ways that it lets
g-getting logo to be careful the knock
of is it for Baker make it number two
the blue break not gonna land it comes
back but it doesn't matter a shutdown
for the best player in the world hoping
to bring one more for SKT is blank now
finds an easy struggling to kill the
beer not gonna matter Blanc gets himself
a solo missile voyage right side a bit
it'll be a shot back on the power of
evil
gets taken out power stays alive on the
backside one more kill coming through
and that's gonna be played as misfits
finally well John a passive gonna have
to kick into high gear ga gonna try and
make once five happens Nick you know
ulti does have flash dodging the first
shot but keep running though honey he's
gonna try and take you death broke it up
down the way both different are
inseparable NATO she ain't gonna sneaky
Connie's gonna go down as well and Ben
my goodness Connie actually maybe not
straps horse to get out of the way
although on there seem to go in for the
other play Chuck wavers goober the
damage isn't quite that [ __ ] bus that'll
wave in that projects bachas is in
trouble
Gandhi fighting where he can it's just a
matter of what they're trying to pull up
after the fact you face looking for the
1v1 wins enough time to pay in place
nine five seven saves mystics life she
ain't complete set
we don't know if he's recalled there's
the bishop uncle
[Applause]
entrance from
ditching its focus on to Rula Nethercott
polcie a in place but the boy goes out
as well as the Boyd's warden those
little crabs are looking for flight the
carnie Foster and offensively
Sam sang survived via gate bodyslam
comes up the audition Connie's not
backward he's got no flash available and
through that gets his first of the game
anything anywhere Sampson County now
crown found out one more time but
knocked back right in a baker's wedding
guard and Karma's gonna catch up to you
again but it all goalie got to come out
I gotta find suppression and they might
just get that first kill they do Samsung
Galaxy on the board looking for more
wolf gonna run away this will be a 2 B 3
as 9 5 7 note access to that slicing
male strip nipple 5 are coming in class
awake it's the Sun down and the
boys see justice but is interrupted
so as he did what's up by that shadow to
teleport me channel by caps insta
flexion so as the birds learn enough to
kill now is there enough to turn this
around idle of Turin for all the shield
of dread locks down two members of our G
to interrupt available picked up G he's
going to survive the bracket stage was
full of fantastic team fights but we're
kicking off our list of the best team
fights with this bloodbath between SKT
and RNG isolated with the flaps right
here comes the dive in a hoody it's over
the fact that they have the first image
nearsighted
try to make them down and they do all
the damage putting stuff on the trainers
that look she's already dead walk
towards the jump away the definitely
better maybe take it down let the other
chases well Baker going towards the
turrets by showering for the damage
[Applause]
find a take of the frontline it will be
coming across rooms eros will find a
couple of routes of the terrible pops is
Logan vulnerability to re-engage and
comes crown he can't even be touch
puffle shuffle for the slow and the
first one comes in his trundle drops a
second as well as Hutton is gone the
rocket afford ruler wants a third
they're going to get a son Andre he's to
lose his life as well
number four and five next up of the
chopping block has beaten he can only
run away what is the chain of corruption
dissuade did he play the chase
so as continues to go to look it's you
know out of genetic sheep it stunned
against the wall a lot of time nobody
has died you kid who's he is once again
the target is cap uses the ultimate to
escape
[Applause]
buthe me next it's a double-kill for
Lucy will be run down these authorities
to him mania has to retreat from the
fight they're able to take down max Lord
they didn't have minions when they
started the fight they make didn't get
much damage time to the turret still
trying to turn they keep losing members
Baker tries to go to the back his eggs
are stops him with what Pete and the
turnaround is happening six to six now
but they need to protect the base that's
a mission and now everybody turns their
attention to the ground he's gonna get
trait for platoon it's not able to flank
at the moment they're all five together
they're going in a hoodie on Sakuni
throws down the subjugate right away
looking at pain and han sama bangs on
the lefthand sama is in the back line
not able to deliver any damage just yet
enough re ignore max ler all very low as
SKT pushes forward wind rising more than
here comes right on top of misfits the
damage is just too much then SKT take
the game under their control that might
be the play play in under two but he's
gonna get away with this foot cord a
stayin alive so we get to prevent the
frontline a lot of health part is
getting pushed down as cuz flash the
weight stays up events when the Sun is
gonna break Brown Sophia's hot look for
the door this was the matter of the site
help give up the camera the thief and
Connor finally to make it for us only
rulers paying alive but he's been cut
short the ultimate Buster shot back
they're able to get onto hoodie here
subjugates gonna make him very tanky if
he gives the right target looking at
Baker and looking to where blanket go
here power of evil on the backside with
hoministe' slips off
yes Cataclysm from blank as Max Lord
goes down and SKT start to bring out the
fight prowess wolf gets himself out
alive as afar he gets taken down by bang
and we can't to see a fight we're
misfits carries on not able to do it
he's coming through with the round warp
hot sama now taking shots from bang he's
looking to get himself forward in the
fight explosive shot not able to take
him down just yet but it doesn't look
like SKT stops here
Blaine goes in a few more shots
depressors there the shop from bang the
kill from blank any moments here
teleport starting to channel percent
backside OH
pick up blue team in here comes in China
vulnerability the first no come to group
already for brown wood for zero and
cutter dropping a 10 second one and it's
going to be a giant stop the backside
this command needs to buy a few seconds
but it doesn't matter a triple go coming
across to actually back in but Kondo
gonna lose his life he'd be the last one
to remain here but he's in a one versus
three and crowd gotta have the damaged
tank means few days about to get excited
Hickam
to find some time Rula flashes in heels
to safety you get what they are into the
wall triple kill picked up through the
fence flashed away to safety now she is
the target Rula not gonna find the
Quadra kill so much damage has been done
and QB sealing up on the war bug so a
nice the shield Hagan is coming from
behind now full HP on this copper
he needs to stop SKT from losing the
flash she's not gonna find a cure for
Hoonah kitty keep SKT a lot mission one
more attack turns to crowd yes the mid
lane stays alive now faker in the melee
range of cuvee but am analyst cho gath
is not a threat they're going to keep
chasing the Chomp is in there is no way
out for Choga SKT will hold on this game
is insane SKT does manage to defend
eventually they kill curates not flash
available as was smite the gymnasium
[Applause]
if she tried to
[Applause]
over the wool Detroit to chase down let
me show who's running for his life he
took done caps in the backyard all of a
sudden the misfits last second Baron
steal and team fight win against SKT
kick off our list of pit plays from the
bracket stage
Blanc is going down Domino goes down to
the fight and that is going to be hot
summer's day today they focus on two
flank and now each nurse looking for
faker wolf wolves gonna be there in the
front scatter with those so he's there a
bit Otto I came here once in began going
over to play the Amir
heading towards the fight near cartoony
literates
power of evil he had no chance to get
out on sama Falls and a misfit is
heading for their base
[Applause]
the boardroom
[Applause]
the Chinese squad looking for a Ford has
the slow lands of perfect register let
me and Uzi is here the Walt is gonna be
bawling Aussie gets himself another six
Dells the game meant light under fire
he's made out the blue shrink if you
kill it you go back to your big date I'm
gonna need only go back again going for
the play
can he get himself in he suppressed the
first
steel and here comes to reengage he
bounces back first blunts to go to
Samsung Galaxy go TTP's in but it's five
before who needs got a lot of places to
go
Baker like little is in flight the flame
from eighty Kenan they've got two and
I'll make it three as beta sports to run
away he stays down his balance and dad
hootie-hoo steel eyes on reckless on the
plank
my name is Margie in the pitch
[Applause]
get kills no control wars for fanatic
there in the toys are full heart and
could knock him away caps not
[Applause]
another one adult doesn't find a target
at phantasticus thought you split up
last but not least the playoff stages
best death brushes tower dives and level
one invades are up next on our list of
the best set played sniffing for an
ultimate he's gonna be the birth mother
something to try and get the unsub been
once do not an office now me stick the
next target Jensen he's also you can see
it man sir chuckling [ __ ] up are
optimistic but I crowd mine they get to
still looking for the third don't get it
all Road their advantages across these
roles cows gonna face akin to a business
settlements gonna be four verses one and
there's simply no way expose of cats by
the second but it doesn't matter and
he's gonna be the target I'm Alex G's
gonna look for reckless Rick the stuff
that rocket
[Applause]
arrrg when they allowed the Gallio to go
through see if they can find a way in
right 3v1 on to let me be still the
flash available to him holds on to
realities a nice place down in this rum
pot so I think Jase comes in that's a
tough way I'm surprised at all what are
you going for the die Baker knows he can
come in afar he tries to get just away
from the turret dodging out on the top
but knock back in and faker that's Tim
Cole for them to get through but here is
this level to gank and we were talking
about buff to buff and they're looking
for po8
buffer playing there's the Nagas flag
and drag turret shot on the blank he's
getting a little closer Auto Attack from
Baker first blood SKT GW use credit they
have to Farsight over to now they're
gone
Jennsen finding the plaintiff through
Devon seconded mystic though allowed to
three here they're gonna take to the
controller
okay check is your economy
Vincent's gonna try to score these
chocolates in safety shield to land in
and he's made getaway hit with an
infernal drape on the table seen I tried
to stick around to kill the inhibitor
that was straight up memory
what does work without
59 5-7 because they cut them off
properly here comes the wall there's no
where we're lucky to go bebop as well
they're going to be thorough for this
one one he'll make it a sec for the
barrier pop beats not thinking the
second coke comes in to zero in the bot
lane yeah you say that's all they want
but that's a lot to ask for here comes
Blanco big lay that taught him confirms
the knock of this could be enough damage
let's bounce prism right into the turf
that knocked back there as well perfect
this just like a bank Rene and mystique
are available buddy Sam goes for it
explosive charge
[Applause]
if you've got something happened absolve
depends W want to shake the bed that
[ __ ]
foreign is but will be picked up by Rula
on - she ate the latest of will 2017 12
let's see what happens here Rui - the
mid laners well looking for a pic out of
that with a knock of the chains of crowd
control blended beautifully first blood
comes in for SKT thanks for watching if
you want more great content be sure to
hit that subscribe button
[Music]